do you still have the belt let me say it
please
looks like it's grown to me yeah there
he is
there he is brett
fred by the way have you ever clocked
how quick does it take bread to get in
the room when you ring the bell because
sometimes forever and a day i have to
actually get up
and leave this room and go to the other
end of the house
brad is it too much for you is are you
cracking from the pressure of all of
these demands of george
look at him he's very happy content
well let him in let him speak george
it makes me feel important it's like i
have something to do with my life
there was a debate around here that uh
george for the first time
we asked him to record a certain song it
was rather bawdy it was
sexual in nature and and and george in
the past has recorded many many songs
for us i talked to
brad about the song no problem if you
don't want to do the song today yeah
right no problem
so reached a point in my life now where
i am i am known as a distinguished
gentleman and that song is
way above my standard
note taken no problem brad we feel this
is your influence
we feel your elevating yeah that you
read through the song
and somehow stop george from doing it
gay people see george as a like a role
model
and i felt like because the lyrics were
hey brad let's go to the ramble and have
uh
romney sex with strangers
that's not the image that george should
have at age 84.
i knew it i knew it i knew that wasn't
george talking
because george has always done it but
the reason we love george is because
he's fun
george you know what i mean and we even
had to invent
a fun george because george is now
becoming more politically correct
would you like to meet fun george guys
fun george come in for
i want george to talk to fun george hi
fun george
hello howard
[Laughter]
oh my good morning george hi brad
my brad is gone brad
my brand you're the one who's not fun
fun george you ring that bell for your
bread and i find it somewhat elitist i
must tell
you i hit the bell with my penis
[Laughter]
you are fun you are fat come in here so
i can blow you on zoom
howard i'll sing any song you want
do you wrestle your brad on sunday for
sexual pleasure go ahead
i wrestle my bread on sundays and
saturdays and summers
in the middle of tuesday
[Laughter]
let's wrestle brad i wonder what fun
brad sounds like howard i wonder does
fun brad have a
uh gay voice i have no idea because he's
never here
get your ass up here brad
where's my dry oatmeal
[Laughter]
fun george i know that real george says
analingus what do you say lingus
[Music]
[Laughter]
and it's not tsunami
different dialects